今天要來當沖
6770的利基店
速度10倍
今天手機不在我手上
特別注意
今天所有教學內容
不是推薦個股
沒有進出賞建議
任何投資都有風險
一定要評估自己是否有這法承擔
準備好
我們當沖開始
你會讓我賺到錢的吧
加油
好緊張喔
第一次是我自己
你想要做多還是做口
還不知道
我等一下
學你
看60K
看60K的壓力
想要做多你就找支撐
想要放空就找我壓力
60K
現在在支撐區
對吧
你哪裡有支撐去 我怎麼會看到支撐
我們再看一次
你的支撐在哪裡
這裡啊
這個這個
沒有啊 它不算啊
對啊 它不算
你應該是看到上面有壓力
還是這根壓力有沒有
大根的黑黑壓力有沒有
這一根
70.4
好 70.4
你就把它當作一個分水嶺有沒有
喔喔喔喔喔 來了來了
沒有 你要先看70.4有沒有過啊
70.4有沒有
他剛才就卡在那邊
第一次
你剛才其實已經有出手一次機會
然後下來你已經賺錢了有沒有
有嗎 現在得上去吧
沒有 剛才有上去一次下來吧
不然怎麼會有70.4
我不知道要聽到我們講
沒有啊 這一定是有衝上去
有人用紅包獲利法已經賺錢了 有沒有
我錯過了 老師你看
你還好 我錯過這個最佳時機了
所以你在開盤前你就要先找好壓力點
你看有人看到70點4搞不好空70點3
你看70點3如果跌到現在698 699你已經賺5角了如果壓力沒有過的話你就可以評估說這邊到70點四你要不要乘三這個風險我看一下你就不會過試一下你空個一張
一張 對
唉唷 OK
風險這70點四
你乘三到696
你就要決定說
那個70點四到底會不會再過
壓力沒有過的話
你看往下它沒有支撐
對啊
往下沒有支撐
你就不要想太多
你就可以用最簡單的5分K
比如說最近的壓力被克服了
5分K
或是均加線被突破了
因為它現在應該是一個趨勢線
5分K
對 開盤多少
開盤就要是69
突破我就可以加空
跌破你可以加空
因為已經拿開了嘛
唉唷唉唷 啊快點快點快點
不會過了啦
你看這時候我已經成交10張
你還在 你現在還在看
這個就是出發的故意啊
好 我現在兩張了
對 很猛的 很猛的
往下你再看下一道支撐
因為目前應該是沒有支撐嘛 對不對
因為它是往下掉
對 那我可以再看這裡嗎
可以啊 前滴也可以啊
這個前滴 那這裡好了
哇 它怎麼反彈呢
68.5
可以啦
最好是能趕快就是找好支撐壓力去判斷它
看你要用我們教的均加線的方向
還是你要用壓力支撐都可以
但是很多人就是學了
然後當下 欸 慌了
懶了 不知道怎麼辦
還是我直接看68.1
我直接掛68.3
也可以啊
你看你就想說你剛才空的點到那邊
你可以賺多少可以先想好
有那個賺培筆賺漂亮
那我給它空一個68.3
買進吧
買進
快點喔 再打個力氣